hello everyone I'm Laura Ingram and this
is Ingram angle from Washington tonight
thanks for joining us the equity Club
that's the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
cost of racial inequity to this country
brings the entire country down holds the
entire country back giving resources
based on Equity understanding that we we
fight for equality but we also need to
fight for Equity advancing Equity is not
a one-year project it's a generational
commitment watch your wallet well you
can't say the voters in 2020 weren't
warned who can forget kamala's Goofy
cartoon message
so there's a big difference between
equality and equity
a quality suggests oh everyone should
get the same amount
the problem with that not everybody's
starting out from the same place
Equitable treatment means we all end up
at the same place
oh I still can't believe that actually
went out now if we had an honest media
this would have been exposed for what it
is on the spot just cartoonish socialist
nonsense because when Joe and Kamala say
Equity what they mean is justify
discrimination and not just based on
race because when Joe and Kamala say
Equity what they really mean is the
creation of a new power Dynamic that's
disguised in very benevolent terms
the equity on the issue of economic
benefit and strength our Administration
from the beginning made a commitment
that we would increase minority and
women owned
businesses getting Federal contracts
we're implementing a once in a
generation infrastructure law with
Equity at its Center I mean that's
sincerely with Equity at its Center
he means that sincerely of course the
word Equity is the antithesis of
equality as guaranteed in our
constitution
forcing outcomes based on phony
subjective sense of what's fair requires
gratuitously punishing or rewarding
Americans based on arbitrary categories
the same racial activists who are
demanding reparations now are the same
ones who influence the president's
executive order on on Equity that was
aimed at advancing equity for all
including people of color and others
who've been historically underserved
marginalized and adversely affected by
persistent poverty and inequality
because advancing Equity requires a
systematic approach to embedding
fairness and decision-making processes
executive departments and agencies must
recognize and work to redress inequities
and their policies and programs that's a
mouthful
but ignore the noble language because
when they use the term racial Equity
it's really not about helping African
Americans it's also not about Equity
it's about helping Advance the Democrats
agenda which essentially is 21st century
socialism
their idea of equity would never include
a scenario under which a government
contract for instance would be awarded
to a business headed by a conservative
black man or a woman over one headed by
a white reliable supporter of the less
left let's say climate agenda
Because unless you fully buy into what
they believe you don't count as being
traditionally from a underserved
community
remember how Justice Thomas my old boss
is treated by the smithsonian's
African-American Museum compared to
let's say the billionaire Entertainer
Oprah Winfrey remember it wasn't until a
year after the museum opened that they
added Under Pressure a small exhibit on
Justice Thomas
disgusting but so predictable
the true aim of their Equity agenda is
to build a new powerful political
machine where leftists get as much many
of the resources as possible
so this Equity lie is seen in how the
Biden team has downplayed the train
derailment in East Palestine
lived here 12 years
how do you just get up and walk away
from that because somebody else's
negligence I've never been afraid to go
home and this is the first time I've
ever been afraid to get home I can't
take anything
from my house my daughter took a bag of
clothes and it launched an asthma with
her when she was trying to get them out
to wash
now these people are both underserved
and potentially poisoned
so where's the equity there
these are mostly middle class Working
Class People
but leave it to Pete who instead of
visiting a community in need after a
real accident would rather play politics
we have heard way too many stories from
Generations past of infrastructure where
you got a neighborhood often a
neighborhood of color that finally sees
the project come to them but everyone in
the hard hats on that project looking
like uh you know doing doing the good
paying jobs don't look like they came
from anywhere near the neighborhood
oh what an idiot does that mean like all
those all white owned townhouses in
Georgetown or the mansions in Bel Air
shouldn't have What Hispanic drywallers
or painters we can now only have
projects run by people who look like the
community what a farce is that because
what It ultimately leads to are
established firms setting up
subsidiaries with a you know on the
surface of minority staffs so then they
then they can go check the box and
compete for that Federal contract the
story is as old as time
just as the left came to dominate
University faculties and came to
dominate Hollywood they want to dominate
all aspects of the federal government
and of course comes with that the
lucrative Government Contracting this is
why they're so afraid of Trump's idea to
reform the Civil Service
the truth is
the look the Democrats have essentially
given up on our system they think it's
racist they think it's evil and they
want to end it
but since socialism can never deliver
better outcomes to people certainly not
better than the American system the
radicals need to rig things in their
political favor it's the only way
and they're kind of jealous of China
with its social credit system and they'd
like to establish the equivalent of that
here
A system that effectively rates you
based on whether you're a member of a
select group and whether you have
certain attitudes or beliefs
so if you have the wrong friends if
you've donated to the wrong groups if
you go to the wrong Church you're going
to be shut out of certain opportunities
this is what they want
they effectively did this in our
universities and in Hollywood and now
they aim to do this in government and by
extension in Corporate America
so everything you hear about
d-e-i-e-s-g it's all the same
it's ditching any objective measure
whether it's like the AP courses in
schools the SATs the acts and even yes
objective assessments via artificial
intelligence yeah you heard that right
as Americans struggle to buy like a
dozen eggs or feel their fill their gas
tanks on their cars don't worry because
the Administration has a plan to
eradicate algorithmic discrimination
that's a thing designers developers and
deployers of automated systems should
take proactive and continuous measures
to protect individuals and communities
from algorithmic discrimination and to
use and Design Systems in an equitable
way this is
anything to avoid what might even
approach an objective assessment
and of course Business Leaders are
bowing to the equity Gods as well
companies like ours must speak up as
allies to the black lives matter
Movement we were on record back in 2016
in supporting a black lives matter
Business Leaders cannot
lend on important issues whether it's
racial Equity gender Equity that's it
agenda is already at play in corporate
boardrooms and yes if the left has its
way they'll eventually expand their
Equity Club to include everything from
the training and hiring of airline
pilots to the training and hiring of
heart surgeons
scared yet well you should be
because their dream is to massively
expand their power by embedding
preferences based mostly on political
beliefs and affiliations under the guise
of addressing systemic injustices
Now call it crony socialism
but let's face it since everything they
do ends up lowering our standard of
living it's the only possible way to get
they can really extend extend their
political reach
uh you still think I'm exaggerating well
guess who's running the White House
Equity show
none other than Obama's left-hand woman
Susan Rice who now runs Biden's domestic
policy shop
now none of this should surprise us
after all our figurehead president does
zero to unite the country he spends his
time telling us how awful it is
you know folks lynching is pure Terror
the crimes trying to vote
trying to go to school trying to own a
business lens for simply being black
nothing more
with white crowds white families who
gathered to celebrate the spectacle
taking pictures of the bodies and
mailing them my postcards hard to
believe if that's what was done and some
people still want to do that
no wonder no
I don't want to laughs at
Abe Lincoln when he urges them to take
the moral High Ground
they say something like your own
President says that you all want to
Lynch people over there why should we
listen to you
well Equity just like all their
buzzwords like diversity and inclusion
or gender affirming care or vaccine
disinformation they're just verbal clubs
to use against dissenters to force you
to give up your freedoms and your way of
life for a fraudulent Utopia don't fall
for it and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else